feeling here for for time he remained
and performed cures on the Indians of
the San Jacinto Valley probably his
first cure first attempts at healing
then he took what small funds he had
accumulated bought a boat ticket that's
why there's no line going from salmon
San Diego to San Francisco and went by
boat to San Francisco and from there
begin another arduous trek down the
Sacramento Valley and across the Mojave
Desert with nothing but of flour and
water to New Mexico it was this
bedraggled spiritually chastened man
that report is likened to the figure of
Christ in the summer of 1895 and they
were not far wrong for when a minister
asked slaughter if indeed he were the
Christ the healer answered I am
soon after slaughter arrived in New
Mexico he began a forty day fast it was
to be the culmination of his preparation
to become a healer toward the end of
July when this photograph was taken you
know in an Albuquerque studio he looked
pale thin and WAN he stood approximately
5 feet line at ninety inches in height
though he impressed reporters at being
as being much much taller
he had extraordinarily large hands and
when he was in good health he had a
massive bill largely due to strenuous
exercising and much of that due to the
fact that he came West initially because
he was suffering from tuberculosis from
this time on he remained in Albuquerque
a guest of prominent residents in the
city's old town as he continued his fast
he treated greater numbers of people and
spoke with reporters from newspapers
across the west the reporters also took
testimonials from people he treated and
his reputation as a christ-like healer
spread across the nation one of the
people who came to see him was Edward L
Fox a Denver coal and grain merchant and
former City Hall aldermen Fox brought
with him a friend and neighbor Henry
Hauenstein who was nearly blind and
slaughter gave Hauenstein special
treatment
regular days after the regular days
sessions had ended Fox was so impressed
with what he saw that he invited
slaughter to visit Denver and to carry
on his mission of healing there to a
greater and greater crowd at first
reluctant slaughter agreed to return to
the city where he'd begun his pilgrimage
two years before but did so when Fox
said he would pay for his train fare
first however slaughter had to complete
his fast this he did with a huge meal a
couple of weeks later a meal that
astounded those who witnessed it now
listen to this after having taken
nothing but water for 40 days Schlatter
sat down to a supper of 11 fried eggs
nine slices of salt pork with gravy
seven pieces of cheese two tablespoons
tablespoons of chili con carne three
helpings of pickled apples a slice of
ripe eight slices of rye bread three
pieces of roast chicken a slice of cake
a cup of coffee and four glasses of port
wine people expected him to drop dead on
the spot
but a doctor who stirred his pulse
throughout the meal found that it
remained normal a week later slaughter
said goodbye to his Albuquerque host and
took the train to Denver he has survived
the fast ending meal but was very ill
and weak all along his route of travel
people in small towns gathered up the
Depot's to be touched by him but because
he didn't have the strength to go to
them he began taking their handkerchiefs
and this was the first time really this
had been done and so far as I know in
the 19th century or in the modern era he
took their handkerchiefs held them in
his hands and returned them he
maintained that the father's power to
cure them would be just as effective
this way as by his own hands when he
arrived in Denver on August 23rd 1895
slaughter went into it retreat for three
weeks and refused to see the public but
talked to occasional reporters then
after that time he went to the Fox home
and was boarded by Edward Fox Fogg
his wife Mary and daughter Annie and a
nephew Leonard current this is a very
small home and there were four people
already living there and they introduced
this stranger into their home and gave
them their their personal bed
the Fox one was located in the hot
located in the Highlands area of North
Denver not far from Fox's coal and grain
business across the South Platte River
September 16 was the day that had been
announced for slaughter to begin the
healing sessions at the Fox home and 300
people were waiting when he emerged at
nine o'clock in the morning within two
days that number had climbed several
fold the size of the crowds took Fox
completely by surprise as did the
shoving and jostling to get to the
healer so Fox quickly built a guardrail
parallel to his picket fence so that
people had to move single-file past the
spot where slaughter stood almost as
many people came to watch as to be
treated up and down the small street you
can see carriages long lines of people
waiting for treatment and very shortly
after opening day vendors of sandwiches
coffee lemonade peanuts and watermelon
the vendors and hawkers lent a festive
atmosphere to the healing sessions but
the crowds were full of solemn curious
and suffering people his routine at the
Fox column didn't vary he began as
healing sessions at nine o'clock in the
morning and quit at three in the
afternoon when he would go to out to the
carriages and treat the people who were
too sick or disabled to come to him he
had a curious method of grasping each
person that came to him he would take
their right hand in his left and left
hand in his right crossways and then
utter a short prayer to the Father at
first he would spend a minute or two
with each person but as the crowds grew
greater he would often treat three or
four people a minute and then often more
frequently when this got around the
slaughter
he'll to the medium of handkerchiefs or
letters people in line began bringing in
their handkerchiefs or and those that
belong to their relatives and friends
people who lived out of town at night
slaughter would serve would ant would
sit and answer hundreds of letters that
came to him each day but these began to
pile up so high that he could not keep
up with them they filled nearly an
entire room in a small in the small
house I have a picture of bundles of
mail but is not very good this happens
to be the first letter healing uttered
at Schlatter
sent out to come to light I expect that
it will be others the healer offered
treatment to everyone no matter what
their age social status race or ethnic
background all he required of anyone was
that they have faith in the power of the
Father to heal him in fact he was so
universal and offering his gifts of
healing that some claimed he was a fraud
for the sole reason that he didn't
require a confession of faith as the
holiness people or later Pentecostal
people did when they were performing
healing acts meanwhile the crowds grew
larger they jumped from an average of
1,000 people a day to 2,000 or 3,000
long lines sometimes three abreast
snaked around the block and passed down
several more blocks charlie cars ran all
day long bringing new arrivals from
Denver's hotels to the Fox home there
was good reason for this slaughter had
announced back in September that he
would be leaving Denver for Chicago on
November 16th this is what Rubio
laughter
as the days of his ministry came to a
close more and more sufferers who came
to see him were from out of state so in
the last days of slaughters ministry
everyone was desperate to see the healer
before he left town the hotels were
packed Union Station was described as
looking like a hospital and Street and
people were sitting up all night long to
get an early place in line pardon me on
the 13th of November a Wednesday the
crowd numbered 5000 people this was the
last day that slaughter was in Denver
and this picture was taken the caption
reads last hour but the photographer
didn't know that when he took that
picture and he put in the caption later
on then suddenly without warning
slaughter was gone two days before his
scheduled departure when the excitement
of his ministry was at its peak he
disappeared as an early crowd of 500
gathered in front of the Fox home on
that grey morning of November 14th all
they saw was a sign posted on a front
porch it read the healer is gone we know
not where as the news spread it created
shock anger outrage and grief hundreds
had traveled to Denver to see the healer
those ecstatics those expectations have
been shattered and these people felt
bitterly betrayed inside the home Edward
Fox explained to reporters what he knew
of slaughters disappearance he had
knocked on his bedroom door at 7 o'clock
that morning he said and got no response
slaughter was normally a light sleeper
so Fox tried a few more times and then
entered the room
on the bed he found a note pinned to the
pillow it read mr. Fox my mission is
finished father takes me away goodbye in
fact however does a show on my book the
note was a deception Edward Fox knew
very well where the healer was as did
slaughters close supporters they had
joined him in a conspiracy
get him out of town so that he could be
on his way before any reporters and
rumor hunters found out about it at
10:00 the previous night Fox it asks his
nephew Leonard Kern to hitch a horse to
his buggy and bring it out of the
carriage house behind the home
Leonard was also to bring a heretofore
unknown white horse named Butte Fox and
slaughter got into the buggy shielded by
you know a robe and the cover of the
buggy and drove past the crowds Kearns
climbed on the horse the white horse
behind them and followed them out of
town the party rode ten miles along
Cherry Creek to the south east and their
slaughter mounted the horse and
concealer on his journey while Fox went
back to tell the crowd that the healer
had disappeared and you knew nothing
about it
nearly two months and 700 miles 700
miles later the horse and rider stopped
at a ranch on a snowy January night in
dat'll in the dáil mountains of New
Mexico 150 miles south west of
Albuquerque when the owner ADA Morley
saw him she was stunned she knew very
well who he was for she had stood in the
lines in October to receive his touch
and a told her daughter that what she
felt was an illumination Morley was the
daughter of a legendary civil rail of
engineer William Raymond Morley who had
built the Santa Fe Railroad over the
rugged Raton Pass between Colorado and
New Mexico a university educated woman
she had built a substantial house and
what in what was became known as White
House Canyon and it was an oasis of
culture music and thought in the wilds
of western New Mexico her three grown
children away at college when the healer
arrived but she was not alone for a cook
and several cowhands left after her
slaughter told Morley that the father
had directed him to a ranch for a period
of rest and retreat from the world when
she recovered from her shock she invited
him in and the healer became a guest in
her home
the next three months during that time
he and his hostess is morally called
herself have long conversations about
religion politics economics and social
issues morally discovered that unlike
the simple cobbler with a gift for
healing that Schlatter had been made out
to be
he had an impressive wealth of learning
and could speak knowledgeably on almost
any subject he had once been a populist
and had educated for political reform
now he believed that the gulf between
the rich and the poor had become so
large that the world was heading for a
great revolution and it wouldn't be a
human revolution the father he told
slaughter told or morally was planning
to destroy the rich powerful and
privileged of all the nations in short
slaughter said the world was heading
toward an apocalypse the war of
desolation foretold in the book of
daniel the father had called on
slaughter to be the messiah of a new age
that would blossom around the globe in
the wake of this destruction it would be
the new jerusalem a millennial order
under God and its namesake City New
Jerusalem would lie in the dat'll
Mountains of New Mexico
this was slaughter said the meaning of
his vision in hot springs two years
earlier and his 3,000 mile walk of
humiliation suffering and privation it
had been a walk he said for all humanity
in fact slaughter provided confided in
morally he was a reincarnation of Jesus
Christ sent to the world this time not
with love but a sword over the next few
months as the world approached the 20th
century violence and social disorder
would prevail up to the Year 1899 when
the words of Daniel would be fulfilled
in the meantime the Father had directed
slaughter to go even further into
retreat to lose himself in the wilds of
Old Mexico at the proper time he would
emerge as God's appointed leader over a
universal utopia of peace democracy
equality and prosperity ADA morally
believed him the conversation she had
with him convinced her that he was the
reincarnated Messiah or very close to it
she implored him to write everything
down about his two-year pilgrimage and
when his difficulties with the English
language grew too great she took his
dictation the world she believed was
must know of his sack of the sacrifices
on its behalf she also wrote down their
conversations and when the time came for
him to depart she asked him if he would
if she could publish it he agreed and
gave it the title that she used the life
of the harp in the hand of the Harper
this was to be a gospel of the new age
when slaughter left the Morley ranch in
late March 1896 ADA walked with him for
a mile or so and they said the Lord's
Prayer together she was very much afraid
for him but he assured her that the
father would watch over him then he said
you will have what will seem to be
certain evidence of my death brought to
you the world will laugh at you for
rejecting but reject it I shall not be
dead I will return to dat'll wait for me
he never saw her she never saw him again
over the next few months Morley worked
on her book got the ranch then finished
it in Denver during the spring and
summer of 1897 it was published in July
but just two weeks before that news came
out of Mexico that rendered the Gospel
of New Jerusalem obsolete the healer was
dead news reports stated that an
American prospect of American
prospecting party for before men from El
Paso in the state of Chihuahua Mexico
had come across the skeleton resting
against a tree high up in the mountains
as bones bleached white and fully
articulated at the top of the canyon a
neat pile of clothing lay next to it
along with the Bible a spanish-english
dictionary a memo book with the name of
Ada Morley on one of its pages and a
solid copper rod shaped like a baseball
bat that had been known to be associated
with the healer ADA Morley had two
reasons than to doubt the reports first
she knew as an experienced Rancher that
freshly dead creatures in the wild
either human or animal do not last long
in the midst of coyotes wolves and
buzzards
nor do old skeletons survive untouched
second she remembered slaughters last
words and that she was to ignore any
evidence of his death so she made plans
to go to Mexico and see for herself and
she was a dedicated woman she came back
and Vince that slaughter was alive or at
least did not die at the top of that
Canyon
everyone knew she later said that
Schlatter had two missing upper teeth
and the skull she examined there had a
full set Morley believed that
slotter had indeed been at the spot but
had received a call from God to abandon
his possessions and follow God's leading
to another place she did not however
have the answer for the present presence
of an unknown skeleton probably
disinterred from a nearby cemetery or
that the entire tableau spoke of a
conspiracy to make it appear that the
healer had died there in spite of her
investigation no one believed her not
even her children still she waited for
the final days that slaughter told it
would come in 1899 and she earnestly
believed in his return but as time went
on she began to have doubts in September
of 1899 she wrote the allotted days of
Daniel will have been numbered by
November unless I again take a wrong
basis from which to compute and how many
people have a strong basis to compute
biblical I am sure slaughter has spoken
the truth he repeatedly told me he could
not would not die and I'm very sure he
will fulfill those words then she said I
am anxious to see that great day for
mankind it will be glorious for his
powers will be vast enough to adjust
wrongs and oppression up to the time of
her death in 1917 ADA morally must have
wondered endlessly about the healer she
obviously knew that the glorious day
that they had both hoped for hadn't
arrived nor believed in time that it
ever would but what about Francis
slaughter she had to have wondered about
his fate if slaughter did not die in
Mexico as he told Morley he would not
where did he go one possibility is that
he dropped out of sight altogether tired
of everything in his life and career but
given his devotion to God I doubted that
on the other hand if you tried to
fulfill the demands of the Father and
love up live up to his great destiny
where would that have taken him my book
the vanish
Masaya looks at just that possibility it
involves my discovery of remarkable but
forgotten book and the Library of
Congress called modern miracles of
healing a true account of life works and
wanderings of Francis Lauder most
remarkable of all its author was
purportedly Francis slaughter himself
and the book was published in 1903 and
the question I faced or that anyone
would face is whether the author of
modern miracles is an imposter or the
real healer as I found out it wants to
find out it's a simple question to pose
but a very complex question to answer
modern miracles can be divided into
three parts first there is the story of
the healers version of his early life
the healer of who's the author of modern
miracles in his early life next comes a
description of Francis slaughters known
career beginning with his emergence in
New Mexico in 1895 and ending with his
departure from a tamales ranch in 1896
last there's the story of Francis
slaughter the author after he leaves a
de Morley's ranch until the present time
that is 1903 so let's begin at the
beginning I want to try at the beginning
of this book the slaughter of Martin
Martin Marek modern miracles offers a
fantastic fantastical account of his
early life
he says his all sation parents brought
the two-year-old francis to america in
1858 and settled in Columbia Tennessee
in fact documents show that Francis
slaughters French Alsatian parents both
died in 1870 and 1871 and leaving
leaving him an orphan at age 14
then modern miracles author writes in
1868 his his his Oscillation father dies
and his mother marries an English
Englishman named Edward Martin later
still Francis gets uncomfortable because
the Tennessee friends he has teased him
about his psychic powers and he returns
to Europe for many years returning in
1884 where he picks up the life of the
known Francis slaughter that's the early
life now let's ferment skip over the
known career go directly to the years
after his departure from a tomb or Lee's
ranch modern miracles slaughter says
that his beloved horse Butte after he
left a tamales Ranch drank alkali water
and died on the way to Mexico the healer
in his grief over his loss abandons his
journey to Mexico and makes his way to
the upper reaches of the Ohio River
Valley and starts a walk down the Ohio
and Mississippi rivers alike another
pilgrimage this is in the summer of 1896
just a few weeks after he leaves at a
Morley's ranch now all of this would
have remained just a made-up story if he
hadn't mentioned in modern miracles that
he was admitted to Good Samaritan
Hospital in Cincinnati on his journey
for treatment of an injury and as it
turned out I checked Good Samaritan
Hospital in Cincinnati and they had
records from that period of time they
had a patient record but from from that
time and earlier not knowing what I
would find took a two-week trip to
follow the healer of modern miracles and
stopped by Good Samaritan on my journey
it took me a while of looking through
the record books but here's what I found
the patient named Johnny Martin born to
Louisa Martin in Columbia Tennessee had
begun on the surface a career as an
imposter offensive slaughter in 1896 or
shortly thereafter
later I found census records from
England showing that Louisa Martin had
given birth to a John Martin in 1859 and
and other census records showed that the
family went from England to Canada and
in 1882 or so they moved to Columbia
Tennessee so there is it there was a
census a historical record of the of
this course of this family going to
Tennessee my question was why would John
Martin and good samaritan hospital 1996
why not simply say he was from England
born in England it's a small small
discrepancy but it made me wonder what
if it wasn't John Martin and good
samaritan hospital it would later become
francis slaughter but francis slaughter
who took the name john martin while he
was trying to lie low in essence after
his deception in mexico immediate may
have needed time to kinda gather his
wits
the vanishing Messiah looks at my
struggle over the answer to that
question in it I propose a hypothesis
that begins with the idea that slaughter
meant exactly what he told Adam orally
that he would return in 1899 to
establish New Jerusalem and why he
decided to take up his mission of
healing again under his own name when he
could have easily if he faked his death
could easily have weathered the father's
call from a quiet the quite obscurity of
a Mexican village why come back in other
words in this respect it's important to
note that slaughter believe deeply in
his mission and that his eyes were
focused directly on the father's promise
of the New Jerusalem to come not on what
happened to him in the world of the
present in other words slaughter didn't
care for the world of Mammon as he saw
it or as it saw him either but only for
the glorious world of New Jerusalem as
its people would regard him in hindsight
after 1899 he was destined after all to
be its Messiah so if you will I'd like
to look at the history of the posthumous
Francis slaughter and make a case for
why he would return to face skepticism
scorn and rejection I'd asked you two to
hold in abeyance your skepticism while I
while I present this hypothesis this
slaughters first national moment of
attention took place in Cleveland Ohio
on June 8 1897 this was two days after
news came out of Mexico that the healer
was dead he and her friend sat down to
breakfast in a boarding house where
other boarders were discussing the
breaking news story Martin's friend
turned to the group and said that's very
queer I was under the impression that
slaughter is still very much alive in
fact he is here with us allow me to
introduce to you Francis slaughter in
fact through the months and years that
followed the man who had spent a few
days in Good Samaritan
Hospital never used any other name but
Francis slaughter and time he let his
hair grow longer slowly and cultivated a
substantial flowing beard slowly just
like the original healers and it seemed
as if he were growing into the part he
had the healers blue gray eyes did the
same height and had the same large hands
that grasped his patient's crosswise as
the healer had done all something he
could have certainly known from
newspaper articles but especially in the
wake of the slaughters death and the
news being so fresh in people's minds
the new slaughterface skepticism doubt
and heavy scrutiny from reporters and
city officials in Chicago in particular
the Tribune and listed a number of
Denverites who compared it to Francis
slaughter one witness said that the
original healer was nothing but a slob
of a Dutchman and he spoke with a strong
German accent well a new how the new
healer seemed to be to them more refined
better dressed and and more elegant and
speech and appearance others recalled
that slaughters hands were rough the
original slaughters hands were rough and
peasant like well the new healers were
long fingered and tapered the Chicago
Tribune reporter spoke in particular
about the air of falsity in the
posthumous healer there is a visible
attempt to act up to his role the
reporter wrote at times the assumed
dignity is dropped the faraway look in
which he attempts to hold which he
attempts to hold disappears and the
divine healer becomes an unprepossessing
and commonplace looking man surveying
with indifferent contempt the crowds of
the afflicted he is victimizing the
healer in fact seemed to demonstrate
that very arrogance when another skeptic
skeptic asked him if you were the Christ
as the minister had an Albuquerque of
the original healer this slaughter said
I'm not a Christ the Christ was a
slaughter
almost everything he did went contrary
to what one would have it would expect
of an impostor in fact the new healer
seemed intent on making himself the anti
slaughter and in doing it in a
self-conscious way it made me wonder
Francis slaughter had warned ADA morally
that false prophets would arise in his
name but that she should ignore them
that prediction had a 100 percent
accuracy rate because he could very well
have been that false prophet
this healer he said pardon after
carrying his healing message his healing
ministry throughout the Midwest and
eastern United States the healer and his
manager went to Atlanta and then to
Birmingham along the way reporters had
noted some of this characteristics both
negative and positive one suggested
sneeringly that he had used that he and
his manager were effeminate another said
that Schlotter seemed to speak with a
peculiar Twain that was somewhat
pleasing to the ear in Georgia the an
Atlanta Constitution gathered witnesses
as the Chicago Tribune had done in
Chicago and one of the witnesses they
spoke to unlike most of them who
discounted this this fraud said that he
had seen slaughter in Denver in 1895 and
he'd noted an almost imperceptible mark
on the right side of the healers nose
this man the Atlanta healer he said had
the very same mark the comment went
largely unnoticed but no one at the time
could have known that a Canton Ohio
woman who had moved to Denver in 1895
had written back home that year and
given a rare detailed physical
description of the healer which meant
mentioned a small mark on the side of
his nose the Atlanta healer then turned
to Birmingham Alabama in what became his
last great healing ministry for there
there he met
married a woman named laverna comer who
had been a healer in her own right and
was considered as a rival of slaughters
in 1895
she lived in Chicago but was visiting
her hometown of Birmingham
within days of their first meeting
slaughter proposed to her and they were
married secretly in Coleman Alabama he
never returned to Birmingham to his
manager or anyone else the two of them
got married went on a honeymoon and
became a healing team that wandered
around the country they did however
although they were successful in this
their marriage began to deteriorate very
quickly within nine months of it in the
fall of 1899 the Verna's husband
threatened to jump out of the six story
window of their home in Chicago's Palmer
house what led to this suicide if that
is unknown but it was a preamble to a
pattern of erratic behavior and
drunkenness that plagued their marriage
from then on again and again they fought
and separated then returned to continue
their healing ministry but an episode in
New York City in 1901 led to a severe
crisis in their marriage police were
called to their apartment and they found
laverna with her eyes blackened packing
her bags and her drunken husband raving
that he was the messiah she had him
committed to st. Elizabeth Elizabeth's
Hospital in Washington DC but when
doctors there found him to be saying she
really and released him
laverna fled back to New York City he
followed her there and is stalking her
he was arrested and committed to a work
heart work house on Blackwell's Island
the jailers cut his hair and beard and
when he learned that laverna had taken
out divorce papers he lost all hope on
his release he wandered aimlessly from
town to town but nobody paid attention
to him they used to think I look like
Christ he said and that gave them faith
now with my hair gone and my wife gone
and the lawyers notification of divorce
proceedings I'm a broken man
laverne his friends and family had long
told her she had married an imposter but
she had not listened to them and
insisted that he was he was he was
authentic however his behavior to her in
New York led her to the point of
actually leaving him for good
Eliza last measure however she traveled
to Denver and met with Mary Fox who had
come to know Francis slaughter well so
she went back to Denver she met with
Mary they had a conversation which no
one will ever know about but laverna
returned from Denver to her husband with
her faith renewed in the fact that he
was the real Francis slaughter she
proposed at that time something new that
he write his autobiography and proved to
the world that he was the real Francis
slaughter he agreed and in February 1903
he produced the book we've been talking
about modern miracles of healing it was
an effort to prove himself as part of
the books launched the couple announced
that Schlatter
would return to Denver and address his
critics casting aside the lingering
doubts about his authenticity he never
showed up in hindsight we can see why
the man who wrote modern miracles did
not attempt to return to Denver
jubilantly and the evidence is in the
book itself modern miracles is a
remarkable book in many respects but one
of its distinguishing features is that
it undermines the three key words in his
title a true account truth and falsehood
vied with each other in this book like
yin and yang and they embrace each other
in the same way
Mary Fox said of Francis slaughter he
was one of the purest of men but there
was cunning in him that same dichotomy
is apparent throughout modern miracles
but no more than in this respect its
author
a description of his pilgrimage around
the West that defied all reason
while the original slaughter had
followed a path that was guided by the
Father modern miracles route was
anywhere it looked like the the
wanderings of a drunken man and yet
there is a more subtle piece of evidence
in modern miracles that suggests this
author was not a native speaker of
English bits of odd phrasing idiomatic
expressions foreign to the English
tongue and what one link was called an
interference of German appears here and
there quite unconsciously in the book
Frances slaughter spent hours and days
studying English but never quite
mastered it either in terms of structure
or accent many questions remain about
the identity of the man from good
samaritan hospital and many things can
be said both pro and con about the
physical and behavioral characteristics
of frances slaughter and john martin AKA
frances slaughter but here's a
hypothesis and elaboration of the
hypothesis that I find plausible I call
it the Daniel hypothesis slaughter beast
his prophecy of Armageddon on the Book
of Daniel and in Daniel chapter 9 verses
24 to 27 a series of weeks amounting to
about two and a half years precedes the
war of desolation that Daniel speaks of
during this time according to the King
James Version Messiah shall be cut off
but not for himself
slaughter might well have interpreted
this passage to mean that he would
supposedly die go into hiding and return
of the proper time in 1899 to establish
New Jerusalem in the interim between
1897 and 1899 he would be living in a
kind of suspended State in terms of the
way he might have thought about it not
able to reclaim his identity as the
original healer but also not ready for
his
personhood at the beginning of New
Jerusalem the best way to play that part
perhaps was to become a false prophet in
the dying corrupt world of the present
while laying out a history of scorn
abuse and disbelief to show the people
of New Jerusalem what he had suffered as
he had walked in the footsteps of Christ
and then in the space of a few months in
1899 the Messiah's entire vision
collapsed nothing earth-shattering
occured that year the only Wars at the
turn of the century were the Boer War in
South Africa and the American action in
the Philippines against insurgents the
war that some believed to have been
Armageddon world war 1 was still 15
years in the future everything slaughter
prophesied in the life of the heart had
come to naught and he was left with
nothing but the damning evidence of his
stage death in Mexico thus he had to
disassociate himself from the great
healer and Messiah of Denver nothing in
modern miracles even hints of the Book
of Daniel the war desolation to come or
the New Jerusalem that slaughters
intelligence even in the improvisational
act of dictating his book to a friend
allowed him to chart a narrow course
between truth and falsehood that kept
his current loyals current followers
loyal while assuring his old supporters
in the West including ADA morally that
the Messiah was indeed dead of course he
didn't return to Denver not because he
would have been shown to be an imposter
but because his deceit might well have
been exposed in his reputation as a
healer forever
ruined
the last 20 years of slaughters life
were marked by continuing troubles in
his marriage including an actual divorce
and remarriage to your a three or two
later and periods in which slaughter
gave up healing to try as hand at other
things but only to return to his true
calling he never gave up his devotion to
spiritualism or this habit of wandering
off for weeks and months at a time which
he and laverna called God's leading in
fact laverna found herself desperately
searching for her husband in 1922 when
she had learned that he had died in a
st. Louis rooming house with an unknown
woman who disappeared as soon as a local
doctor came to tend the dying man the
woman who was most likely a spiritualist
nurse who had been taking care of him
but the scandal led laverna on arriving
in st. Louis to accuse the strange woman
of murder a coroner's report the next
day concluded that the man had died of
thisis an acute condition of pulmonary
tuberculosis
laverna was then outraged because her
husband's body had not been embalmed and
he was therefore unable to bring himself
back to life
laverna left st. Louis with instructions
to bury her husband in Miamisburg Ohio
where they had lived for a time but
something went wrong his body remained
in the plights funeral home unburied for
the next 25 years discovered with other
unburied bodies in 1945 it went into a
common grave in the municipal cemetery
and years later was removed with the
other unknowns to Mount Lebanon cemetery
west of st. Louis on what it used to be
Eastern Avenue Francis Francis slaughter
told people in 1895 that he would
disappear in return in a different form
I contend that when he left a de
Morley's ranch he walked out of history
as one of the greatest healers of the
19th century only to return as a
counterfeit of himself that was his
destiny and his personal tragedy I thank
you
I can walk around we do have microphones
available for your questions I'll start
off David can you tell us anything about
the you know what class or ethnic lines
were followed with his followers I mean
that were they a particular type of they
were all over there were there were
social lights in Denver who went to see
him and wrote about it there were people
who were at that time of course it was
the height of the economic depression
following the silver crisis a silver
crash of 1892 there were homeless people
they were they were all of all classes
and types there was a German family who
I wrote about brought beer and
sandwiches to eat while they were
waiting in line to the to the envy of
other people the pictures that some very
few here that I shown there are many of
them showing the crowds and you can see
that there is a wide range of economic
and social variety there as well as he
he healed people who were brought from
Indian reservations he took in that
didn't take him but touched and it gave
his Healy touch to people who were
brought in from the Colorado State
Hospital mental hospital there was no
one he turned away and it was very clear
that some of the more traditional
evangelical like ministers were very
upset with this because he did not ask
for a confession of faith e-tail anyone
they'd say hello anyway they don't have
to believe in Christ
it's his true father
I read that one time that he left
because he was upset that people were
paying to buy places in line yes as a
matter of fact the common notion that
was that and it's been true for a
hundred years
he disappeared because he was angry with
the kind of materialism the fact that
people were selling their places in line
or were paying to have to be able to
move closer up in the line
they'd have small boys they'd pay small
boys you know a few dollars to sustain
in line at four o'clock in the morning
so they could come in at two o'clock in
the afternoon and be right there and it
was a it was an idea that this is why he
disappeared that was that was current at
the time and actually promoted by his
friends but if he had been offended by
that sort of thing he would have left
within a week he disappeared because he
had a mission to disappear he knew he
was going to walk out of history because
he believed that he would be walking
into a timeless era it was it's like an
end times belief
is there any evidence that he actually
did heal people yes there is some
reporters actually there were many
reporters who stood to his left when
people were moving through the line and
they would see what kind of reaction
people had when they when he touched
them he never asked it by the way what
they went they had and the reporters
would kalam on to these people if they
showed that they had been able throw
away their crutches and walk but one of
the most I think telling episodes was of
a woman who had boils all over her face
and as the reporters were interviewing
her those boils disappeared now the
cause of this you know I I think I put
myself in a position if I have a problem
and I need a healer to deal with it and
I'm standing in front of 2,000 people
and I've stood in line for six hours and
I'm coming up to a christ-like figure
what kind of emotional psychological
psychosomatic effect might that have I
think that could have been true most of
his most of the people who he who
claimed to have been healed had
rheumatoid arthritis or aches and pains
that sort of thing
although he did claim to have there was
one dramatic healing and where a
twelve-year-old girl
daughter of the Wyoming National Guard
had been blind in one eye and after
slaughter treated her her father wrote a
note that she read having her hand over
the good eye it was quite dramatic and
there were a few episodes of that
anyone else analyst want to challenge my
hypothesis I have to ask about the the
the relic that was at the skeleton the
baseball bat size staff whatever
happened to that the bat the actually
the the the copper rod that Schlatter
had with him he got in Denver he had
forged in Denver a friend friend paid
for it and it was forged in Denver and
he took it to back to New Mexico and it
became widely known as he was traveling
back to New Mexico
he used it presumably for exercise and
when he was crossing the border into
Mexico and he did go across the border
into Mexico and despite what 1903
slaughter said he stopped at a ranch and
the Cowboys were interested in what the
rod was for and he was showed him he
took it and he spun around and let it
fly and he said where the rod landed in
the direction to which a point it would
be the direction the father wanted him
to go and there once of course the point
of South because he was going to Mexico
the rod is an interesting story about
the rod long when I just shortened it
Edgar Hewitt who was a well-known
archaeologist Southwestern archaeologist
and became the director of the Museum of
New Mexico and of the of the Center for
American research both of them housed in
the palace of the governors in Santa Fe
he was the own archaeological
exploration in Mexico in in 1906 and he
ran across what was presumed to be the
grave the unburied gravesite of Francis
slaughter and he learned from his guide
was kind said about having seen this man
ten years earlier as a boy he what came
to realize that
this was Francis slider and he in the
village Casas Grandes he got the rod he
didn't do anything with at the time but
he came back about 17 years later and
then he offered to pay the village jefe
or mayor money to hire schoolteacher in
exchange for the rod he took the rod
back and it's now in the Museum of New
Mexico the New Mexico History Museum I
was on display for a while but now it's
come back into the collection I won't
tell you its significance at this point
so why don't you think he could heal
himself of tuberculosis and whatever is
in that sanatorium for what's that why
do you think he couldn't heal himself of
tuberculosis and whatever he was in that
good samaritan hospital for you know
there are a lot of a lot of
discrepancies and just continuities in
spiritual things and you're saying why
can't why couldn't he heal himself with
TB I don't know
his wife apparently believed he could
heal himself from of death he could
bring himself back to life but not after
he'd been involved hey Mike
the body the 22 years to have that
sealed and stay there did you ever learn
why that I took so long for them to find
it
oh yes no I did there were there were
several in 1945 this was and just just
when the European war is ending st.
Louis officials found several unburied
bodies throughout the city and some of
them were in warehouses some of them
were you know this one was in the
basement of the funeral home apparently
at that time in the 20s when when some
of these bodies were prepared they had a
very powerful embalming fluid of some
sort because slaughters body as
newspaper accounts had it was very well
preserved I think I think it was just a
lapse that he in and professional
standards and mortuaries and I certainly
don't know why laverna who actually had
arranged to have her husband's body
taken to miamisburg for burial never
never went back and checked her never
went to his grave but I think I think
what happened was that she may have been
told that it was had been destroyed
somehow accidentally I can't believe
that she would simply walk away and not
have anything I mean she went back to
him too many times
I was wondering was there any financial
benefit that he received that he was you
know they originally slaughter yes I did
the he refused with he refused any offer
of money or gifts everything and and
when people forced money or gifts on him
in one case there's a rumor that he took
whatever dollar or whatever it was and
gave it to someone who was poor he lived
on you know the the uh uh at the hands
of people who took care of him the Foxes
took care of men in Albuquerque there
were people at you hear of him and this
is one of the reasons why most people
believe that second Francis slaughter
John Martin ika Francis slaughter could
not have been the original because he
took coins and he paid his managers and
one of the reasons he was kicked out of
one town was that the city fathers said
you know if you have to to pay managers
and why should we be funding that but
slaughter was the original was he lived
as Francis st. Francis of Assisi would
have lived as his namesake was though
he's not answer your question yes so in
other words he was sort of lived and the
same way that Christ that he met what he
never took money he live he lived with a
vow of poverty well during this time how
war how well publicized was this the
first time I heard it but that don't
mean too much because I'm not that world
knowledge about such things though but I
would think that that would been you
know well known all over the world
although you know that day in time you
know things didn't travel that fast why
wasn't he
well-known all over the know the
universe yatra because he walked out of
he disappeared this was a conscious
decision he made and when the news came
out of Mexico that he was dead the book
that ADA Morley had prepared which was
the gospel of the new age was virtually
null because it's Christ did not did not
return so I think that was there for a
period of time and I will say this I I
didn't mention them but there were
several other there were several other
Impostors who took his name I talked
about him in the book and one of the
reasons he may have been rejected was
because he's in the company of several
but the that period of time from early
part of the turn of the century to about
1922 when he died a number of these
people were wandering around the country
and they were creating very sensational
stories about their acts and then after
the last of them he was one of the last
to die off during the 30s almost nothing
and it was only after World War two that
people started writing again looking
back at Francis slaughter and what
happened is that over a period of well
from 1945 to the 1990 when I started
getting interested in it there may have
been every five or ten years an article
in newspaper magazine chapters in books
would come out on him and
be kind of flurry of excitement and then
it would die down again I think one of
the reasons why that happened is because
no one who had written about him really
addressed why he disappeared really
looked at what his motives were even if
you discount the idea that he may have
come back nobody spoke about the intense
religious prophetic